happy forgiveness day my fellow Silo
fans this is where I ask forgiveness for
all the theories I've gotten wrong which
surprisingly hasn't been too many for
those of you are new here I have not
read the book so I'm going in completely
blind and will only use sleuthing to
uncover the secrets of The Silo and boy
do we have a lot to talk about today as
always I've left timestamps below so you
can see all the topics I'll be covering
it's time to clean let's get into it who
would have thought an object so
frivolous as a Pez dispenser could
Propel the story forward and offer a new
and exciting clues about The Silo last
episode we saw Juliet retrieve George's
illegal Pez dispenser Relic telling us
that in order to investigate George's
death without raising eyebrows she'd
need a good reason so she breaks into
Douglas trumbull's apartment and plants
the Pez dispenser in his medicine
cabinet for Paul Billings to find if the
murderer of marns in the mayor was
collecting relics he may have been in
contact with other enemies of The Silo
we also learned that if you're a member
of the judicial you have your own set of
keys to your apartment that aren't
available to the sheriff it's likely
then that Juliet used her truth badge to
pick the lock on trumbull's apartment
just like she did to Patrick Kennedy's
supposed apartment last episode there's
also this hand-drawn portrait of
Trumbull and someone who could
potentially be his father I wouldn't
normally have found this odd if it
weren't for Billings somewhat lingering
on it for a beat the dispenser is put in
a relic bag similar to police evidence
bags but there's this symbol on the
front which looks an awful lot like a
biohazard sign just to highlight how
much these things are feared we'll later
find out there are two Relic databases
one operated by the sheriff's department
and the other by judicial which
apparently is far more comprehensive
last episode we were introduced to this
Vault behind sims's desk and in this one
we get to actually go inside it where we
see dozens of relics of varying sizes
including detailed reports of each Relic
pertaining to their origin and
possession history whether the these are
all of judicial's relics or just some
remain to be seen through judicial Relic
database offers information like whether
or not an object was pre-silo if an
informant was involved and the
classification of said relics the Pez
dispenser itself is object 1175 so we
can assume there are at least a thousand
such relics in judicial's possession in
addition to the computer database are
these journals perhaps in the interest
of secrecy they are written down so as
to avoid any digital hacking if it were
stored on the computer these journals
offer vital information regarding the
relics history including interviews of
those who possessed it Witnesses and
confidential informants there's even
what appears to be blood stains on some
of the paper as we'll find out Regina
acted as an informant against George but
when judicials searched the apartment
they never found anything this is likely
because he had already stashed it way
down by the machine something that
struck me as particularly odd was
George's tattoo in the first scene at
first I thought it was some sort of
staircase similar to the one found in
The Silo but later on we'll see a
drawing in Regina Jackson's apartment
that looks oddly similar it's only later
when we find the Amazing Adventures in
Georgia book that these spirals belong
to a nautilus shell and there are plenty
of similarities between these types of
shells and The Silo itself including the
spirals and Chambers Regina was George's
lover before Juliet and she paints a
pretty Grim picture of their
relationship according to her George was
simply using her to deal in the buying
and selling of relics you see Regina
came from a large family which allows
her a greater network of trust when
dealing with objects that The Silo has
deemed illegal you're less likely that
your cousin is going to turn you in when
you're like hey do you have any of those
relics lying around what drove George
were these big questions about the silo
questions that could get you arrested
he'll later tell Julia that some of
these include what's outside what's
beyond what the sensors can see and how
long they been there with the biggest
question being what if everything you
knew to be true was in fact one big lie
George's fascination with relics was
likely fueled by A Relic passed down in
George's family through generations and
at the end of the episode we get to see
what this is amazing adventures in
Georgia a travel guide for kids I even
wonder if George was named after this
book this book shows what life pre-silo
was like and contains images Juliet
could never have imagined including
dolphins and forests on the front page
we can see the names of George I'm
assuming his mother Anne and Aunt Gloria
we've already met someone named Gloria
in the show who also asked questions
about the silo could she be George's
aunt but there's a bit hidden on the top
left in cursive the word Melody it's not
capitalized so likely not a name does
the book also mean that the silo is
somewhere near Georgia possibly we did
find out the constellation Cassiopeia
was visible from the screen that is if
you believe it to be true through and
this constellation can only be visible
from the Northern Hemisphere this book
is a great addition to the plot since it
will provide Juliet that drive to search
for the truth prior to this episode her
main focus was to bring Justice to
George and find his murder but as she
tells Martha in a crisis of Faith she
believes George may not have been who he
said he was Regina painted George as a
man who used her to get what he wanted
and the reason he moved closer down to
Mechanical had more to do with his Silo
Obsession than anything what better
person for him to get romantically
linked to than Juliet who had access to
all these places and may provide further
help in his quest for answers so Juliet
is never sure whether George's love was
genuine now it doesn't really matter
since she has proof that those in charge
do not want people in The Silo knowing
of these powerful relics that show what
life was like pre-silo and just a quick
reminder if you like these types of
videos please be sure to like And
subscribe every little bit helps the
channel out since episode 1 we've been
teased that something is not right with
the mirror in Holston and Juliet's
apartment Holston even left a note
saying double the flowers in the mirror
now we know this is to obstruct the view
of those surveilling all the members of
The Silo and it also begs the question
how did Holston find out about this and
if he knew about this what impact did it
have on his decision to leave The Silo
as someone who hasn't read the books I
have to go by my gut here and think this
has something to do with whatever was
behind that Janitor's Closet at the same
time we also need to be open to the idea
that this could be somewhere other than
the silo completely but this dude looks
as though he's wearing a janitor outfit
and the other guy looks as though he's
wearing something you'd find in The Silo
now janitor dude here says they have to
wake someone up perhaps their boss the
first person who comes to mind is Sims
there's also another person that Regina
mentions a man who knows everything
everything
everything he comes at night but pay
attention to that last line he comes at
night the other Watcher is hesitant to
wake up this mystery person because it
is night so are they the same person
Regina says this person is not judicial
which would eliminate Sims they could be
two different people it could be Sims
but now goes to bed early because he has
a son or that Sims didn't hold that job
when Regina was questioned years ago
there's a lot at play here to prevent
these watchers from prying into her life
Regina has fixed aluminum trays against
her walls but admits she isn't sure if
they work or not Gloria also thought
someone was listening in on her when
Allison came to visit in episode 1. not
a major update but Juliet receives a
letter from Ellis down in recycling
early on in the episode stating that she
hasn't found what she's looking for but
will let her know if that changes back
in episode 4 Juliet asked Alice if she
had found a hard drive while cleaning
out holston's apartment it's the hard
drive that George traded Regina for the
a book a big reveal this episode is that
Paul Billings has the syndrome the
syndrome is some sort of disorder that
results in involuntary twitching shaking
flashes of pain impaired balance and
movement and could lead to the complete
shutdown of the nervous system
apparently it's against The Pact to not
disclose if you are experiencing these
symptoms especially if you're in a
position of power like Billings it looks
like Juliet will keep billing's Secret
in exchange for her being allowed to do
things well let's just say not be by the
book we also get our first look at
Paul's family wife cat and daughter
Claire it's through their interaction
that we learn the syndrome is not
something that can be passed genetically
or from person to person what was going
on with judgmentos she says she isn't
feeling well we see her drinking some
sort of seltzer water and she just looks
downright sick this really didn't have
anything to do with the plot so I'm
assuming it's setting something up
there's no indication as of yet if this
is Sims is doing my favorite mystery
from last episode was Lucas and the
constellation if you haven't seen my
video for last episode definitely check
it out there are no stars tonight but
Lucas is here anyway because he's come
to see Juliet I'm curious if Lucas's
love interest in her will grow as the
two uncover the secrets of The Silo if
George liked Juliet for the wrong
reasons will Lucas like her for the
right ones Martha gets the MVP of the
episode giving Juliet a much needed pep
talk to continue her search for answers
she basically states that fear has kept
her locked up in that grungy mechanical
room and considering she looks on this
painting of her and another woman it's
safe to say this was maybe her former
partner one who is briefly mentioned in
a past episode I'm thinking this woman
has something to do with why Martha
hasn't left her room in 20 years now we
turn to that part of the video where we
look at the season trailers to see if we
can pick up any additional information
just a reminder that I'll only be
looking at clips that pertain to new
information we receive this episode
check out this image of Bernard and Sims
looking like they're in that
surveillance room we'll later see this
image with his the same lights and a man
on the bottom left who looks like the
Watcher from the end of episode 6.
perhaps Sims here is being shown the
footage of Juliet looking at the book
Gloria here in some sort of hospital
setting accompanied by these type of
SWAT members entering long-term care I
wonder if this has anything to do with
Gloria's name being in that book there's
this shot of Bernard telling someone
quote the clock is running there isn't
much time yet since the next shot is of
Juliet getting tackled in the same corn
field I wonder if he's letting Juliet
know that Sims is on to her since we saw
him in that surveillance room but now I
want to hear from you what are your
thoughts and theories on what's going to
happen next thanks for watching be sure
to like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember let go of whatever it is
you're wrestling with
finish the job